me learning to cook porsche is just kind
of my first step into really
understanding this cuisine hi i'm andrew
ilnicki and today i'm making my family's
borscht recipe so today we're making
borscht which is a ukrainian beet soup
my whole family is ukrainian all of my
grandparents were born there i very much
feel like i grew up in a ukrainian
household so i eat a lot of ukrainian
food so often borsch is made with beef
stock and beef meat but today we're
making the version that my family eats
around christmas time we observe in no
meat christmas eve so this is a
vegetarian bush so this is way more
mushrooms than my mother would ever use
i got a little carried away here usually
it's two or three mushrooms or
traditionally one left hole and whoever
gets that mushroom has luck for the next
year so when you have dried mushrooms
the first thing you need to do is
reconstitute them with a little bit of
water so you'll soak them until they're
very soft and you don't want to discard
the liquid either and growing up i was
always aware that ukrainian food eastern
european food it was not one of the sexy
popular world cuisines you know it
wasn't french food it wasn't pasta pizza
sushi and it's taken me a long time to
really appreciate the nuances of the
cuisine and really how big of a scope it
is if you look at that part of the world
it's pretty big there's a lot of people
there eating a lot of delicious food me
learning to cook borscht is just kind of
my first step into really understanding
this cuisine that is my family and my
identity and i remember when i was
learning this recipe from my mom in her
pots at home it works out where when you
use this proportion and amounts of
vegetables you just fill the water to
the top so here we just need to submerge
the beets but in hers it's you just max
out the pot and i think that's a very
ukrainian
immigrant way of thinking you know i'm
gonna make this harsh i'm gonna take the
time to do it i'm gonna make it the most
delicious as possible
it's great to make a large amount it's
kind of the only quantity you can make
with porsche you just make a lot
once you've added the water and the
beets you're essentially just cooking
everything in stages so that it reaches
the right tenderness at the same time so
we're going to cook the potatoes for a
few minutes and when they're soft we'll
add the carrots so that those two
vegetables kind of come to be perfectly
cooked at the same time if you've ever
watched a tasty video all the way to the
end you might have heard a guy say oh
yes and that's me this happened during a
very early tasty shoot it was actually
before tasty was called tasty and me and
adam bianchi who you might know from the
worth it videos we're working on this
all-day breakfast burger we're reaching
the last of the daylight and so it was
either this video was going to come
together at this moment or it was not
going to happen when adam put that final
i think it was a hash brown waffle on
top of the burger and the egg yolk broke
in the perfect way i was just so
relieved and so into how delicious this
burger was that i exclaimed oh yes we
kept it in the video and eventually
became sort of a tasty sound effect
borsch can't be beat oh yes
oh yes
you